la sífilis es un tipo de enfermedad o
infección de transmisión sexual es más
frecuente en hombres que mujeres
la infección suele afectar a los
genitales que son los órganos
reproductores dentro y fuera del cuerpo
también puede afectar a la zona anal y a
la última parte del intestino grueso el
recto
también pueden verse afectados los
labios la lengua u otras partes del
cuerpo los gérmenes que causan la
infección son pequeñas bacterias
enrolladas o en espiral llamadas
treponema pálidoum
se puede contraer la bacteria a través
del contacto sexual con una persona que
tenga sífilis especialmente alguien que
tenga úlceras sifilíticas en los
genitales o la boca o a su alrededor las
mujeres embarazadas que tienen sífilis
también pueden transmitir la enfermedad
al feto las bacterias pueden entrar en
el organismo a través de Pequeños cortes
o rasguños en la piel o en el tejido que
recubre muchas de las cavidades
corporales incluido el tejido que
recubre la boca los genitales o el ano
en pocas horas las bacterias pueden
propagarse por todo el cuerpo y causar
la infección
a partir de entonces la sífilis tiene
cuatro etapas de enfermedad con síntomas
variables que pueden aparecer a lo largo
de un período de 10 o más años la etapa
primaria la etapa secundaria la etapa
latente y la etapa terciaria
en la etapa primaria en unos pocos días
o semanas pueden aparecer una o más
úlceras muy infecciosas pero a menudo
indoloras llamadas chancros
se producen en el lugar por el que las
bacterias entraron en el organismo como
el pene
la vagina el ano el recto o la boca
estas úlceras pueden durar varias
semanas Si no se trata la enfermedad
progresa la etapa secundaria
durante esta etapa además de las úlceras
puede aparecer una erupción cutánea en
una o varias zonas del cuerpo
otros síntomas que pueden aparecer en
esta etapa son fiebre dolor de cabeza
dolor de garganta inflamación de los
ganglios linfáticos pérdida del cabello
en áreas focalizadas pérdida de peso
dolores musculares y fatiga
dado que otras enfermedades también
presentan estos síntomas a veces se
considera la sífilis como la gran
imitadora
la etapa latente u oculta suele comenzar
uno o dos años después del inicio de la
infección
durante esta etapa las úlceras y las
erupciones cutáneas ya no son visibles y
otros síntomas ya han desaparecido no
obstante sin tratamiento las bacterias
permanecen en el cuerpo esta etapa puede
durar años y la persona Igualmente puede
transmitir la enfermedad a otros
la etapa terciaria de la sífilis es poco
frecuente Pero puede parecer Entre 10 y
30 años después del inicio de la
infección durante esta etapa las
bacterias pueden propagarse a muchas
otras zonas del cuerpo entre ellas el
cerebro y los nervios los ojos el
corazón y los vasos sanguíneos el hígado
los huesos y las articulaciones
los síntomas dependerán de Hacia dónde
se haya propagado
desarrollar sífilis terciarias muy grave
porque puede dañar los órganos internos
y causar la muerte
el principal riesgo de contraer sífilis
es tener contacto con una úlcera durante
las relaciones sexuales vaginales anales
u orales con una persona que tiene la
infección tienen un riesgo mayor las
personas sexualmente activas que son
hombres que tienen sexo con hombres
tienen el virus de la inmunodeficiencia
humana o VIH toma un medicamentos para
prevenir el VIH tienen una o más parejas
sexuales que tienen sífilis
en cualquier etapa la sífilis no tratada
puede propagarse a otras zonas del
cuerpo por ejemplo la neurosífilis se
produce cuando se propaga el cerebro y
los nervios los síntomas de la
neurosífilis pueden incluir dolores de
cabeza debilidad muscular y dificultad
para moverse problemas mentales como
confusión o dificultad para concentrarse
recordar pensar o tomar decisiones
la sífilis ocular se produce cuando la
sífilis se propaga a los ojos los
síntomas de la sífilis ocular pueden
incluir dolor o enrojecimiento en los
ojos cambios en la visión o incluso
ceguera
Y si la sífilis se propaga los oídos se
llama otosífilis los síntomas de la
autosífilis pueden incluir pérdida de la
audición un pitido o zumbido en los
oídos llamado acúfeno
mareos o vértigo que es una sensación de
que usted o todo lo que le rodea se
mueve o da vueltas
si cree que puede tener síntomas de
sífilis o quieres saber más sobre ella
consulte a su médico